hors assurance bonjour à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue pour cet entracte
science tout nouveau tout chaud où nous
allons parler d'un sujet polémique à
souhait une variante du créationnisme
qui veut se donner des airs de vraie
science sans en être une
le dessein intelligent que certains
osent même appelé créationnisme
scientifique on va évacuer le débat tout
de suite si vous pensez que l'évolution
ne peut pas fonctionner tout seul mais
qu'elle a besoin d'un petit coup de
pouce d'une force surnaturelle venus
d'on ne sait où
alors vous êtes le tenant officielle
d'une pseudo science c'est un peu mieux
que d'être un créationniste fixiste on
entend par là un créationniste haut
perchée qui s'imaginent que l'évolution
n'existe pas il faut évidemment avoir un
rapport assez décousu avec la réalité
pourquoi en cela puisque nier
l'évolution en revient à dire que dans
un monde où le climat change ou les
continents dérive où certaines roches
s'érode et d'autres se former ou l'adn
accumule des mutations les espèces ne
changerait pas non attendez j'aimerais
insister là dessus les espèces ne
changerait pas selon eux donc le climat
change pas d'adaptation les continents
rentrer en collision et ramène des
espèces invasives aucun effet aucun
changement
rien les espèces ne font rien pour
survivre une aberration alors même
qu'elles ont tout le bagage de mutation
et de brassage génétique nécessaire pour
y arriver
tenez vous portez vous même en moyenne
entre 30 et 100 mutation qui n'existait
pas chez vos parents vos enfants seront
aussi différents de 30 à 100 mutation et
leurs enfants après eux et ainsi de
suite pendant les siècles et les siècles
et ben les fixiste eux ils disent que
même au bout d'un million d'années a
accumulé limitation il ne se passera
rien ce qui apparaît aussi sensé que de
dire que les d'une gigantesque ne sont
pas elle-même fait de l'accumulation de
petits grains de sable que les choses
soient claires si chaque être humain est
génétiquement différent de tous les
autres humains alors il est impossible
que l'humanité de deux générations
successives soit la même humanité
donc oui évidemment que l'humanité ait
évolué puisque son patrimoine génétique
change constamment d'une génération à
l'autre
l'évolution c'est le changement le plus
marrant avec les fixies c'est que dans
leurs efforts borné à nier les choses
les plus évidentes ils en viennent même
à nier l'existence de la granite et quoi
ils croient pas en la théorie de la
gravité ah non non non non c'est parce
que j'ai dit j'ai dis qu'il
l'existence même de la gravité pour eux
la gravité n'existe pas à temps là tu
vas un peu fort là le créationnisme est
une démarche franchement anti
scientifique
on est d'accord mais je suis presque sûr
que les fixiste ne nie pas que quand on
lâche une pomme elle tombe
et ben si tout comme l'une des plus
flagrantes preuve de l'évolution et le
fait qu'on retrouve les espèces aux
caractères les plus primitifs plus
profond dans les strates géologiques que
les espèces au trait est plus évolué par
exemple des animaux qu'on qualifie de
poissons sont apparus avant ce qu'on
appelle des amphibiens eux mêmes apparus
avant ce qu'on appelle des mammifères et
des reptiles
ça marche aussi avec l'évolution de
l'homme les australopithèques ont pressé
dès les premiers membres du genre homo
ce un petit cerveau qui ont eux-mêmes
précédé les membres du genre homo à gros
cerveau la raison pour laquelle ce
registre fossile documente si bien
l'évolution c'est parce que la gravité a
fait s'accumuler les fossiles dans
l'ordre les espèces sont apparus c'est
ce qu'on appelle le principe de
superposition syli à une table avec un
verre posé dessus je peux sans me
tromper affirmer que la table était là
avant le verre la seule alternative
possible c'est que le verre et défier la
gravité donc en niant que l'évolution se
soient produites les fixiste ni que
l'accumulation des fossiles on nous
venons de parler existe donc il n'y que
la gravité fait s'accumulent et les
objets qui tombent vers le bas tenez
vous le pour dit
renier l'évolution ce n'est pas
seulement renier les évolutionnistes
sait tirer un trait sur toute forme de
logique scientifique même la plus
élémentaire bon on a déjà bien tapé sur
le fixisme dans cette vidéo la alors
juste au cas où on vous la remet alors
le dessein intelligent maintenant c'est
effectivement un peu plus intelligent
que ça mais pas de beaucoup
les tenants de cette pseudo science
pense que l'évolution oui oui mais sans
une intelligence supérieure pour la
guider
or non dans les candidats convoitent ans
le prix de l' intelligence suprême guy
dans l'évolution on retrouve bien sûr en
tête de lice tout un panthéon de
divinité mais aussi les inévitables
extraterrestres et évidemment les
éternels veut fait pas mais de fait que
poser la question ta gueule tu ta gueule
moktad l'habitat donc et olivier arrêter
de croire que c'est un combat des
attaques contre vous vous n'êtes pas le
centre du monde qui dit dessein
intelligent dit donc intelligence une
intelligence qui aurait conçu la
biodiversité qui l'aurait façonner de a
à z de façon intelligente
alors je le répète pour que ça rentre un
t il
jantes on est donc en droit d'attendre
que cette intelligence a fait les choses
comme il faut qu'elle ait suivi une
sorte de cahier des charges cosmique
afin que tout soit pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes que la nature
fonctionne bien que tous les rouages des
écosystèmes soit bien huilée
un argument qu'on entend souvent dans la
bouche des tenants du dessein
intelligent et celui que la nature y
trop bien fait pour être le fruit du
hasard
dans ce cas le hasard s'oppose à la
fameuse intelligence suprême dont ils
défendent l'existence cela négligent
évidemment que la théorie de l'évolution
explique très bien le fait que la nature
soit très bien fait puisque elle invoque
l'existence de la sélection naturelle de
par la sélection naturelle la nature ne
peut que fonctionner correctement
puisque s'il a des rouages ne fonctionne
pas il meurt sans descendant c'est la
dure loi de la nature et le hasard n'a
rien à voir là dedans
les évolutionnistes ne crois pas que
tout est dû au hasard si pensa que dans
sélection naturelle il y a le mot
sélection et puis tout cela c'est sans
compter le fait que ce spoiler alert la
nature est loin d'être ce charmant havre
de paix idyllique est parfait
la nature c'est sale c'est impitoyable
et surtout la nature n'est pas bien fait
il existe des epic fail de la création
des aberrations de la nature si énorme
qu'elle ne devrait pas exister
en tout cas pas dans un monde parfait
nous en avions fait un petit florilège
dans cet épisode 6 mai en quelques mots
on peut résumer tout ça part pourquoi
existe-t-il de par le monde plusieurs
espèces qu'ils accomplissent la même
chose comme par exemple les fourmiliers
en amérique du sud les oryctérope en
afrique les pangolins en asie où les
équipes né en australie
pourquoi une seule espèce ne suffirait
t'elle pas pourquoi les éléphants père
de thil toutes leurs dents avant même
d'avoir atteint leur espérance de vie
maximale les condamnant à mourir
prématurément de faim pourquoi les
baleines ont-elles des ponts soit
l'organe respiratoire le plus stupide
qu'on puisse imaginer pour un animal qui
vit sous l'eau et enfin pourquoi la
colonne vertébrale humaine est courbé en
quatre au lieu d'être droite
la réponse des évolutionnistes et simple
la sélection naturelle est un filtre
impitoyable oui mais imparfait qui
laisse donc passer des petites boulettes
surtout quand il s'agit de relique d'une
histoire évolutive lointaine les organes
qui ont une origine lointaine et
profondément codé dans l'adn met du
temps à partir voir ne partent jamais
comme les poumons des baleines hérité de
leurs ancêtres qui marchaient à quatre
pattes et vivait sur la terre ferme
on attend encore les réponses des
tenants du dessin animé
jean pas si intelligent que ça
apparemment alors généralement c'est là
qu'on nous sort l'argument de la
complexité
oui parce que changer de conversation
c'est quand même bien plus facile que de
répondre à une question qui fâche
certaines parties du monde vivant sont
si complexes qu'elles ne peuvent pas
être apparue sans un petit coup de pouce
cosmique
bon déjà on va passer sur l'arbitrage
était totale voire même l'invalidité du
concept de complexité en sciences
naturelles qui est quasiment impossible
à définir correctement et certainement
une simple création de notre esprit
l'horloge nous paraît plus complexe
qu'un caillou car nous focalisons
immédiatement sur les rouages
mais si on se tourne vers la chimie
alors l'horloge je n'ai fait que d'un
métal chimiquement simple alors que le
granit est composé de dizaines
d'éléments chimiques pourtant c'est bien
le premier qui est fabriqué par un
horloger et le second qui est naturel et
c'est à ce niveau que le intelligent
dans dessein intelligent a son
importance
en effet la théorie de l'évolution
classique prévoit tout à fait qu'un
certain niveau de complexité puisse
apparaître mais à une seule condition
cette complexité va être moche
imparfaite voire même inclure des
composants totalement inutile voire
contre-productif iwuy l'évolution
fonctionne par addition de mutation par
dessus un système qui est censé être
fonctionnel tant qu'il est vivant on
s'attend donc à voir de nouvelles
fonctions apparaître par dessus des
fonctions préexistantes
on ne s'attend pas à voir une fonction
soudainement remplacée par une autre ou
encore moins l'une des fonctions
disparaître petit à petit avant que la
nouvelle ne soit 100% opérationnel
la sélection naturelle ne le permettrait
pas on a donc deux prédictions soit
c'est le dessein intelligent qui a
raison et la complexité est belle et
élégante car elle est spécialement conçu
façonné poursuivra cahier des charges
d'une précision d'horloger soit c'est la
théorie de l'évolution qui a raison et
dans ce cas la complexité est un foutoir
innommable truffé de résidus d'anciennes
fonction perdu des reliques inutile
d'une histoire évolutive passé les
exemples de structures complexes pas
elle également complexe mais au
contraire trop complexe pour être le
fruit d'une création intelligente sont
nombreux penser aux flagelle des
bactéries un grand classique du dessein
intelligent qui est un véritable monstre
de complexité une usine à gaz car
l'ingénieur n'aurait aucun mal à
optimiser
si ça avait été conçu intelligemment ça
serait autrement plus simple et
harmonieux un autre exemple favori des
créationnistes scientifiques ces laïcs
pour sûr c'est de la belle ouvrage
un chef-d'oeuvre de précision oui mais à
un détail près les récepteurs de la
rétine sont à l'envers
oui vous avez bien entendu le câble qui
relie les récepteurs cônes et bâtonnets
au cerveau se trouve du mauvais côté du
coup il faut qu'il passe devant les
récepteurs cachant la lumière au passage
est troublant donc la vue avant de faire
demi tour de nouveau pour plonger dans
le crâne direction le cerveau vous
parlez d'un design fait intelligemment
l'évolutionnisme lui y verra une
cicatrice de l'évolution
fondamentalement imparfaite mais celui
qui veut y voir l'oeuvre d'une
intelligence qui nous dépasse va devoir
revoir ses ambitions à la baisse pas de
quoi se sentir dépassé
prenons enfin l'élément le plus
fondamental de la vie est l'un des
arguments préféré des créationnistes
contre l'évolution l'adn le raisonnement
est simple basée sur des faits
vérifiables et parfaitement sensé pour
faire de l'adn
il faut des protéines et pour faire des
protéines il faut de l'adn
donc d'où est venue la dna la base et
les protéines
c'est l'argument de l'oeuf et de la
poule se tait les grands et pointe
habilement il n'a qu'une bien connu du
scénario évolutif de l'origine de la vie
l'adn n'a pas pu sortir de nulle part
mais les évolutionnistes ne savent pas
d'où non pas qu'il n'est pas quelques
hypothèse intéressante mais si que
conjecture appuyés par des indices peu
nombreux donc à point pour les
créationnistes sauf que sauf que quoi
décortiquant le mécanisme de synthèse de
l'adn pour faire de l'adn il faut donc
de l'adn on est d'accord c'est adn passe
par des protéines pour être transcrits
en arn puis par d'autres protéines pour
être ensuite traduit lui même en
protéines ça fait beaucoup de protéines
en effet mais tous les élèves niveau
lycée ont vu ça à l'école je ne crois
donc surprendre personne
oui bon bah jusque là tout va bien est
donc belle et donc là rien qui te choque
banon n'y a rien qui me choque adn
transcription traduction rien de
choquant ah bon tu trouves pas que ça ne
peut pas très optimisé comme système u
aurait pas genre que je ne sais pas
comme une étape intermédiaire qui
servirait un peu à rien oui bon ben on
pourrait se passer de la transcription
mais bon c'est pas bien grave moins bien
grave
sa double juste la quantité d'efforts à
fournir pour générer de l'adn tu
appelles ça pas bien grave
je veux bien accordé des points au
dessein intelligent mais encore
faudrait-il qu'ils démontrent
l'intelligence de ce design et l'est où
l'intelligence la abbaoui la
transcription en fait c'est juste une
perte de temps
c'est genre ok voilà 50% de ce que tu
vas faire dans ta vie ce faire un truc
qui ne sert à rien qu'à faire perdre du
temps un processus qui lui
tellement vitale je veux mon neveu la
transcription c'est l'épisode 8 de la
saga star wars c'est comme le h dans
hawaii ça sert à rien et du coup elle
est où l'ailé grande complexité là
dedans
il est où le travail fin du grand
horloger omniscient il en a fait quoi du
cahier des charges jour de la mise en
bouteille du bouzin et jean mimi je
crois qu'on a un problème avec ce genre
la base de toute la vie elle-même les
évolutionnistes pense que cette étape
surnuméraires ce passage obligatoire
mais futile par la rn est une relique
d'un ancien temps le monde à arn une
époque aujourd'hui révolue où la rn
était la seule molécule codante du code
génétique de nos ancêtres avant que le
cercle vicieux il faut de l'adn pour
refaire de l'adn ne commence de l'autre
côté l'explication des tenants du
dessein intelligent c'est de dire que le
grand designer il est trop intelligent
alors on sait pas ce qu'ils voulaient
vraiment faire et même que la rn message
et sa soeur à des trucs par ci par là
quand même alors bon à mes maigres
consolations à et j'aime mieux arrêter
tout de suite ce qui aurait l'impression
que la théorie de l'évolution est une
vieille théorie qui devrait être
remplacé par une théorie plus jeune et
plus dynamique déjà la théorie de
l'évolution d'aujourd'hui n'est plus
celle que darwin a mis en place il ya
quelques 150 ans elle a progressé s'est
amélioré et s'appelle désormais la
synthèse évolutionniste ou théorie
synthétique de l'évolution
la théorie de l'évolution elle même
évolué en fonction des découvertes
récentes darwin c'est du passé
merci de le laisser reposer en paix et
par ailleurs le créationnisme et
scientifiques quant à lui n'a rien de
nouveau de frais ou de révolutionnaire
c'est au contraire un bon gros papilles
des familles au moins aussi vieux que
darwin lui-même
et oui des gens qui croyaient que des
coups de pouce magique faisait évoluer
les espèces il en avait déjà durant
l'angleterre victorienne et je veux bien
sûr parler de owen owen
tu veux dire wayne comme dans jurassic
world et non je veux parler du seul et
unique du terrifiant et pétrifiant
d'uglas sang et menaçant
il paraît que face à sa plume acerbe le
pacifique darwin lui-même aurait déclaré
chérir sa haine envers ce grossier
personnage il s'agit bien sûr de ceux
ricciardo wen
[Musique]
ah oui owen et est créationniste oui son
petit coup de pouce cosmique à lui il
l'appelait le pouvoir créateur tout un
programme
et il ya mes préférés ceux qui doutent
de l'évolution parce qu'il croit qu'il
n'ya que les moutons pour suivre l'avis
des scientifiques
oui c'est toi que je regarde là toi qui
croit être un résistant qui refuse de
porter un masque qui te prend pour un
fier guerrier luttant contre la
pitoyable matérialisme scientifique qui
tu imagines que la science éradique la
liberté de pensée et l'ouverture
d'esprit
en réalité il existe 200 pays dans le
monde et de ses 200 pays il n'y en a que
30 dans lequel plus de la moitié de la
population pense que l'évolution est
vrai ça laisse 85% du monde connu ouvert
au créationnisme et au dessein
intelligent donc non vous n'êtes pas un
flocon de neige merveilleux unique et
subversif dans un monde peuplé de
darwiniste vous faites au contraire
partie de la vaste majorité oppressive
et anti scientifique qui dominent le
monde
c'est vous qui jouez le jeu des
gouvernements totalitaires qui ne
veulent rien entendre de la théorie de
l'évolution car ça remettrait les
fondements de leur domination en
question bref c'est vous le mouton de
l'histoire alors si vous tenez à
contredire la théorie de l'évolution
grand bien vous en face mais donnez nous
au moins des arguments correct faire
appel à ouais mais darwin il a dit que
nenê n'ya ça ne marche pas vous pouvez
par exemple parvenir à démontrer
l'existence de quelque chose que la
théorie de l'évolution ne prévoit pas
comme par exemple l'existence d'un gène
de l'homosexualité
bah oui si l'homosexualité génétiquement
programmée alors ça veut dire que ce
gène se transmet malgré la sélection
naturelle
donc soit ce gène de l'homosexualité est
liée à une autre fonction et dans ce cas
ce n'est pas un vrai gènes de
l'homosexualité à proprement parler ou
alors il s'agit d'un vrai gènes de
l'homosexualité et dans ce cas la
sélection naturelle n'existe pas spoiler
alert depuis trente ans qu'on en parle
et qu'on le cherche personne ne l'a
encore trouvé pas mal de fausses alertes
et de commentaires nauséabonds deux
personnalités politiques et religieuses
oui mais toujours aucune preuve
en fait on a même toutes les raisons de
croire qu'un terrigènes n'existe tout
simplement pas non pas qu'il n'existe
pas quelques déterminants génétiques
favorisant l'homosexualité mais un ou
plusieurs gènes uniquement consacré à ça
et c'est niet
si la nature est bien faite et que nous
sommes parfaitement conçu vous pourrez
aussi nous expliquer sans problème
quelle est la fonction de l'orgasme
féminin non non non non pas la fonction
du clitoris ça c'est trop facile
la fonction de l'orgasme féminin
pourquoi l'orgasme féminin existe les
femmes mettent en moyenne plus longtemps
à jouir que les hommes donc il n'est pas
nécessaire à la reproduction
alors elle est où la conception
intelligente c'est une blague c'est ça
les évolutionnistes vous répondront que
l'orgasme existe chez les autres
mammifères chez qui il déclenche le vul
à sion après l'accouplement n'est
humainement n'ont plus besoin mais comme
on l'a dit plus tôt dans cette vidéo la
théorie de l'évolution prévoit que les
organes ne disparaissent pas aussi vite
que leurs fonctions et pan dans les
dents et j'ai pas fini de parler
merci et les menstruations 1 ça sent pas
bon c'est incommodant possible sauf fait
mal ça fait des tâches et puis surtout
ça sert à rien contre eux passent le
plus clair de notre vie a pas vouloir
d'enfant de toute façon oui c'est vrai
que non mais et puis les poulains les
poules et évacuent leur revue de façon
vachement plus propre et utile on
appelle ça pondre un oeuf c'est vrai que
non mais et puis votre grand horloger et
l'a ainsi supérieur il préférait les
poules csii préférer les poules va enfin
je veux je veux dire non puis tant qu'on
est sur le sujet parlant du sexe un non
parce que pour être compliqué là c'est
compliqué par contre l'élégance simple
et millimétré du grand architecte je
cherche encore ses chaussées moite ça
fait jamais les bd quand on le veut
vraiment puis c'est cher payé pour du
brassage génétique en ont mais les
bactéries elles elles ont droit de
s'échanger des gènes sans sexe et pas
nous
pourquoi parce que le grand coup de
pouce intersidéral il préfère les
bactéries les oeufs et les poules et des
poules bio % temps qui suit
l'accouchement non mais quel est le tai
chi à inventer l'accouchement jour que
si j'attrape d'affaires est en baisse
c'est bon c'est bon ça va on a compris
l'idée tu vas prendre un petit lexomil
homme qu'il examine une camomille
évidemment comme la plupart des
créationnistes tenant du dessein
intelligent défendre aussi généralement
une interprétation bien être aux grades
des textes sacrés où les menstruations
sexualité l'homosexualité sont au mieux
des tabous et au pire des oeuvres du
diable c'est pas demain la veille qu'ils
apporteront des réponses en c et
objective à toutes ces questions mais au
moins on pourra pas dire que c'est la
faute des scientifiques si le boulot
n'est pas fait merci à tous
ah et puis les cormorans tiens
parlons-en des cormorans les oiseaux
d'eau qui n'ont même pas de glandes
urbigène du coup ils peuvent pas un
terme à billy zeller plus et puis la
glande sûrs au pij yens 1
encore une idée de génie au lieu d'en
remettre une couche chaque plume par un
haka un met une seule un d'une grosseur
et puis on va dire qu'on va la mettre
sur le croupion montante un endroit bien
inaccessible qui surtout surtout à les
oiseaux on leur donne pas de bras comme
ça ils seront bien embêté pour étayer
leurs sécrétions imperméabilisante un
dessein intelligent manque